Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du gut ins neue Jahr gekommen?
Ja, du weißt ja, wie ich ins neue Jahr gekommen bin.
Stimmt, wir haben zusammenge- Ja, wir waren ja zusammen. Stimmt, wir waren in der Oper zu Silvester.
Richtig.
Und die endete schon 21 Uhr, weil die alten Leute zur Party wollten.
Richtig, aber wir ja auch noch.
Ja.
Insofern sind wir beide gut ins neue Jahr gekommen, beschäftigen uns mit Literatur, beschäftigen uns aber auch mit Ergüssen von CEOs, die jetzt auch Gastbeiträge in Zeitungen veröffentlichen. Zum Beispiel Elon Musk schreibt in der Welt, warum die AfD die einzige Rettung noch für Deutschland ist.
Also jetzt hast du gesagt, Elon Musk hat den geschrieben, ich hab ihn nicht gelesen.
Ja, ich hörte aber, wie dieser Artikel zustande gekommen ist. Man hat es sich ja jetzt nochmal genauer angesehen und es scheint wohl so zu sein, dass 93 Prozent dieses Artikels AI generiert sind.
Ja, was ich finde, the medium is the message. Wir müssen darüber eigentlich mehr reden, als geredet wurde.
Ja.
Denn nicht nur hat Elon Musk eigentlich keine Probleme in Öffentlichkeit zu finden, ihm gehört ja Twitter, sondern dass er ausweicht auf andere Medien und allein das er ausweicht ist ja schon Thema gewesen, aber das handwerkliche, die Manufaktur dieses Textes, muss ja wirklich unterirdisch gewesen sein. Ich kenne natürlich nur den letzten Satz, der nochmal auf Alice Weidel und so hinausläuft, irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Ja, dass Alice Weidel nicht Hitler ist, da sie eine lesbische Frau ist.
Das kennen wir von Gad Saad.
Ja, da musste ich direkt dran denken. Gad Saad, das ist ja der Philosoph, den Elon Musk so toll findet, aber Philosoph wirklich in Anführungszeichen, der dann sagte, ich hab gerne Hunde, Hitler hatte gerne Hunde, bin ich jetzt etwa Hitler.
Daraufhin, als wir den Clip im Podcast spielten, haben uns ja Leute darauf hingewiesen, dass das ja ironisch war.
Ja, ja, ja.
Dass das ja etwas aufzeigen sollte. Na gut.
Nee, das zeigt eigentlich nichts auf, das zeigt auf, wie blöd diese Leute sind.
Ja, genau, das hat sich viel aufgezeigt.
Ja, es ist sehr interessant. Und die Frage ist ja, warum veröffentlicht er in der Welt? Also die Welt ist ja kein Medium, wo man vorkommen muss. Das ist eine Zeitung, die lesen so wenige Leute, dass sie noch nicht mal mehr als Bordbeilage im ECE liegt. So war das ja früher in der ersten Klasse. Ist auch passé, weil das Ding immer liegen geblieben ist. Es wird ein paar Paywall-Leute geben, aber eigentlich ist das ja unter Fernhaliven. Also hätte Elon Musk das in diesem Podcast hier gesagt, hätten das vermutlich mehr gehört. Ja, aber dadurch, dass es natürlich dann publikvoll, er publiziert in der Welt einen Artikel pro AfD, hat das natürlich entsprechende Wellen geschlagen. Und die Frage ist, wie ist dieser Artikel da reingekommen? Diese Frage kann man nicht klar beantworten. Es gibt aber einen sehr interessanten Artikel im aktuellen Spiegel von Vicky Bagel und Anton Reiner. Die schreiben über die, sagen wir, Verbindungen zwischen Matthias Döpfner und Elon Musk. Und dort ist zum Beispiel zu lesen, im vorvergangenen Jahr feierte Döpfner seinen 60. Geburtstag in einer Villa im italienischen Luca. Eine Berichterstattung darüber ließ er juristisch unterbinden mit der Begründung, sie sei nicht von öffentlichem Interesse, es sei eine rein private Party gewesen. Die Gäste hätten die Kameras ihrer Handys abkleben müssen, heißt es. Unter den Feiernden war, so berichten es mehrere Quellen übereinstimmend, Elon Musk. Und er war dabei nach Spiegelinformationen nicht allein. Als Begleitung habe er die rechtsradikale niederländische Influencerin Eva Vlaarding-Bröck, eingeflogen Vlaardinger Bröck heißt sie, bekannt als Reporterin des rechtspopulistischen Portals Nius und politische Aktivistin. Regelmäßig verbreitet sie rechtsextreme Verschwörungsmythen, etwa über den vermeintlichen großen Austausch. Auch sie habe mit Döpfner gefeiert, heißt es. So, wir wissen auch, dass es eine Nähe gibt zwischen Peter Thiel und Matthias Döpfner. Wir wissen, wie sehr Peter Thiel gerade die Trump-Administration zusammenstellt. Gibt es überhaupt irgendjemand, der nicht im Office von Peter Thiel arbeitet? Fragt man sich, es sind wenige jedenfalls. Und wir haben auch hier noch dokumentiert. Im Frühjahr 2022 schrieb Döpfner eine Nachricht an Elon Musk. Zu der Zeit stritt das Unternehmen Twitter, wie die Plattform X ursprünglich hieß, mit Musk über dessen geplante Übernahme. Die Nachrichten wurden während eines Gerichtsverfahrens in den USA offengelegt. Döpfner schrieb, warum kaufst du nicht Twitter? Wir managen es für dich und errichten eine wahre Plattform für freie Meinungs- Also dieser Artikel ist ganz interessant, der zeigt die Seilschaft. Ich verweise nochmal auf unseren Salon zu Peter Thiel, da sieht man ein bisschen, wie ein Westgeisteskind er ist. Und meine These ist ja, wir erleben jetzt in Österreich, dass die Rechtsextremen an die Macht kommen und es ist nicht mehr ein großer Protest da. Und es ist auch so, dass die, sagen wir mal, Industriellen in Österreich die FPÖ gut finden und die ÖVP gut finden und eigentlich jetzt sagen, das ist ein Match. Die ÖVP wollte ja zum Beispiel die Mehrwertsteuer anheben. Dagegen hat sich die SPÖ gestellt. Dann hatten natürlich auch die Liberalen da noch ihren Anteil, dass das nicht zustande kam. Aber man kann sehen, also es sollte eigentlich wieder Druck mehr auf die ausgeübt werden, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, die nicht so viel haben. Und jetzt sieht man, wie sich also aus dem Kapitalismus durchaus wieder faschistische Strömungen herausentwickeln und die passen auch dann wunderbar zusammen, den Industriellen ist es ganz recht. Ich glaube, ganz so weit sind wir noch nicht in Deutschland. Was wir aber erleben können und ich glaube auch nicht, dass Friedrich Merz einer wäre, der eine solche Koalition machen würde, also eine schwarz-blaue Koalition, um das klar zu hören. Ich glaube aber, dass es in der CDU Leute gibt, bei denen man sich fragen kann, ob es noch so große Unterschiede gibt. Nicht zwischen der Höcke AfD, aber wenn wir jetzt gerade sehen, wie Weide sich fällt, wenn wir auch sehen, dass Gra durchaus transatlantischer sich jetzt gerade äußert, und uns ansehen, nicht was einzelne Redakteure jetzt bei der Welt gegen diese Veröffentlichung sagen. Die sind ja im Prinzip kleine Angestellte. Auch wenn sie große Namen haben, sind sie keine Angestellte. Aber was da sich so an der Spitze tut und Peter Thiel und all das, dann glaube ich schon erleben wir jetzt gerade, dass man an der einen Hand noch Margot Friedländer führt und mit der anderen schon nach Alice Meidl greift.
Ja, das ist genau das Bild. Liebe Frau Friedländer, liebe Margot. Sie wurde noch mal tief ausgeatmet und im Grunde ist sie auch so ein bisschen mediale Geißel, weil sie ist 103 Jahre oder so. Sie kann sich ja nicht wehren. Sie kann ja nicht wie Marcel Reichranitzky auf die Bühne stürmen und sagen genug mit dem Theater und so. Also in deren Sicht, das sind wirklich interessante Zeiten, die allerletzten Holocaust- überlebenden Leute noch auf der Bühne mit das Ende ein. Dieses, nennt man das nicht?
Unwissendlich, die sind dem ausgeliefert.
Mit 103 Jahren ist man dem Leben ausgeliefert. Also sie ist sozusagen so entschuldigt. Du hast mir ja eben schon verraten, dass du das Buch, das wir heute lesen, nicht so gut fandest.
Ich finde es entsetzlich.
Du wolltest es abbrechen.
Ich hatte die Idee, dir zu schreiben, wir lassen es, wir nehmen was anderes.
Was ein Dowum ist.
Und du sitzt hier mir gegenüber und sagst, so ich habe so viele Notizen, war aber auch wirklich gut.
Also ich hatte, weil ich, ich bin wirklich überrascht, weil ich hatte, also wir können ja kurz in die Manufaktur hier uns auch mal offenbaren. Typischerweise reden wir überhaupt gar nicht über das gemeinsame Buch, bis wir dann im Podcast darüber reden. Also dass ich gerade überhaupt noch mal vorher so gesagt habe, ich fand das Buch gut und du nicht, ist schon interessant. Insbesondere mit dem Verweis auf, wo ist der Widerstand? Sollten wir nicht, wenn der amerikanische Präsident sagt, wir fallen in den Irak ein, eine Million Leute auf der Straße haben und zwar bis Februar. So und jetzt wird irgendwie Grönland. Und wo ist der Widerstand? Ich hab heute morgen eine Story aus der Bundeskanzlerin, also ich hab's reshared, das ist ganz witzig. Typischerweise stehen wir ja unseren Regierungen kritisch gegenüber. Wir sind ja mündige Bürger, aufgeweckt und nicht dem Pöbel, der zugehörig, dem sich der Bundeskanzler allerdings verschreiben muss. Der braucht ja eine Mehrheit. Und ich erwische mich, dass ich den Bundeskanzler teile und zwar unkommentiert in voller Länge, wie er es gesagt hat, nachdem er Kanada, also nachdem Kanada Thema war. Ja, so. Und das finde ich schon ganz interessant, weil wir das jetzt auf einer Ebene verhandeln, die wir alle nicht persönlich kennen, aber aus Erinnerungen immer so mitschleppen. Die gute Gesellschaft, es findet eine Klausur statt. Leute treffen sich in Seon oder wie es heißt oder wo auch immer oder sind in Erwartung von solchen Treffen und dann hängt das Schicksal der Welt davon ab, wie so eine Interaktion verläuft. Also das transaktionale Bündnis, dass man dann spontan eingeht mit Trump, weil er halt zugegen ist. In der einen Stunde klärt sich einfach, wie es so läuft. Wenn sich da Leute zerstreiten, zerstreiten sie sich und dann wird das auch die nächsten vier Jahre nicht gekittet. Irgendwer wird abgewählt und so und dann mal gucken, wie es mit dem Nächsten läuft. Also irgendwie so. Wir haben eine Gesellschaft, die sich darüber verständigt, wo ich auch sagen muss, ich habe ja schon immer so gedacht, wozu denn Demonstration auf der Straße? Also ich habe mich ja häufiger nicht kritisch, sondern ja so nachfragen, wozu? Also wenn jetzt 20.000 Leute in Frankfurt eine Demo machen und Frankfurt ist keine besonders große Stadt, nicht mal eine Millionenstadt, dann bekomme ich das hier nicht mit. Und wenn ich es mitbekomme, erfahre ich vielleicht noch zu welchem Thema, aber von Argumentationen und so sind wir ja ganz weit weg. So jetzt haben wir also keinen öffentlich sichtbaren Widerstand gegen Trump. Leute sind mit Feuern in Los Angeles und Neuwahlen in Deutschland beschäftigt.
In Österreich auch kaum Demonstrationen gegen Kick-Tal.
Genau, Österreich passiert, als Heider damals kamen, gab es ja gleich EU-Sanktionen und so was.
Ja, da war richtig was los in Wien.
Genau. Und das wird nach alter Sehgewohnheit noch als aha, jetzt haben wir so Defizite, wir sind so nachlässig, die Zivilgesellschaft müsste mal und so weiter. Aber das Angebot, das sie hat, ist ja nur ein alter Muster zurückzufallen. Also jetzt ein Demozug durch Frankfurt, das ist ja absurd. Von daher werbe ich so ein bisschen für eine neue Sensibilität, die Interaktionen ernst zu nehmen. Gefühle und Gemütszustände. Wir lernen hier gleich einen neuen Grundbegriff kennen, den du wahrscheinlich einfach überlesen hast, aber ich werde dir das nochmal und den Hörern auch vorstellen. Und Ruhmann hat ins Büro Bücher mitgebracht, zum Beispiel dieses. Umgangsformen heute, aber dieses heute ist 1970. Entsprechend ist es produziert. Es ist ein krasser Schmöker. Vielleicht kann ich noch kurz sagen, wir hatten die Woche auch ein Corporate Therapy aufgenommen mit Mary und Human über das Buch Süß von Angratlin Plusty. Angrastin Plusty. Und im Kontrast dazu Rutger Breschmanns, worüber wir häufiger, was ist mit dieser Arroganz und Überheblichkeit der Mächtigen? Wir haben dies geschafft, durch diese Ochsentour durchzukommen, um am Ende das große Medienspiel zu machen. Und da kamen wir darauf zu sprechen, dass es auch ein Gespräch von Lars Weißbrot mit Ijoma Mangold, in deren Podcast, die sogenannte Gegenwart kam, wo die beiden sich über Streit unterhalten haben, in dem Lars Weißbrot aber darauf hinwies mit Nina Power, die sind ja in so einem Dreier aber immer nur Dialogwechsel, mit Nina Power konnte ich mich ordentlich streiten, mit dir Ijoma bleibe ich lieber da, was die Regeln erlauben. So. Und das ist finde ich der Kern dessen, was uns künftig beschäftigen wird, ganz doll. Überall halten wir uns noch an Regeln, die sozusagen eine dritte Partei, eine Institution, eine Geschichte, eine Tradition will ja immer, also eine dritte Entität hat so Regeln aufgeworfen. Und damit wir nicht ins völlig orientierungslose, unbefleckte Land sozusagen kommen, orientieren wir uns an der Regel. Oder, also das wäre sozusagen das Verhältnis Ijoma-Mangold-Land, Lars Weißbrot. Oder klären wir es alles künftig, wie Lars Weißbrot mit Nina Power streiten wir uns, auch jenseits der Regel, weil wir wissen, dass die persönliche Beziehung es aushält. Wir brauchen keine dritte Kraft. Wir brauchen kein überbordendes irgendwas befehlgebendes. Ich würde es mal so befehlgebend sagen. So und das ist super interessant, weil dieses Buch von 1970, das ein echter Schmöker ist. Hier geht es ums Promenieren während Tanzveranstaltungen.
Ganz wichtig.
Oder Theater. Was ist der große Unterschied? Die Pause im Theater, die Pause beim Tanz. Beim Tanz zeigt man den anderen Anwesenden, was man von einer Person hält. Man tanzt mit ihr. Man weiß aber, diese Person ist nicht alleine. Sie hat ein soziales Netz mit sich, Familie. Wir begrüßen also in der Pause die Familie ausgiebig. Die Pause ist nur dafür da, das soziale Netz der Person, mit der wir zum Tanz erschienen sind, zu grüßen, zu begrüßen und zu holigen. Im Theater, in der Pause grüßen wir beiläufig Anwesende, die wir kennen, denn die Pause dient dem Gespräch über das Theater. Wie geht man mit Alkohol um? In dem Falle ist der Tipp, wir stellen Flaschen oder Gläser, die wie Weingläser, also Weingläser, aber wir füllen da auch Saft ein und so. Es muss bunt aussehen, die man soll sehen, dass wir kein Alkohol trinken, aber man muss jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit Alkohol trinken. Schlagen wir unsere Ehefrauen? Nein, das machen wir natürlich nicht. Die christliche Lehre und so weiter gilt hier nicht mehr. Wir machen das ein bisschen auf Augenhöhe. Wir wissen alle, wie das abläuft. Humann hatte auch noch parallel dazu ein zweites Buch, Sekretärinnenwitze aus der selben Zeit. Das sind 50 Seiten anrüchiges Zeug. Also da bleibt von diesem Anstandsding nicht zu tun. Aber das Witzige ist, in diesem Buch wird deutlich. Wir klären es vor Ort miteinander. Wir haben keinen Twitter in der Hosentasche. Niemand postet und shitpostet uns irgendwie. Keiner macht einen Shitstorm, weil irgendwas beobachtet wurde. Alles wird in Interaktionen geklärt. Es gibt gar keine überbordenden Regeln. Es gibt nur so Gewohnheiten, Traditionen, an die man sich hält. So und jetzt will ich eine Beobachtung schildern. Also in dieses Buch, das ist ein echter Schmö-Card, da kann man sich richtig seitenweise einspringen. Es war wieder Kongress. Und ich war das erste Mal 2012 beim Chaos Communication. Genau, also der Chaos Computer Club macht am Jahresende eine große Veranstaltung. Es treffen sich so 10.000 plus Leute und gründen so für vier Tage ihre eigene kleine Welt. Abgeschottet, Grenzziehung, diejenigen, die ein Ticket haben und die anderen. So und dann sind halt die, die ein Ticket haben dort. Und 2012 war das Jahr, in dem auch der Kongress gerade von Berlin nach Hamburg gewechselt ist. Also aus einer, wir haben hier Samplees, kleine Gruppen rotten sich zusammen und dann zeigt jeder dem anderen, was man so tut und das Bühnenprogramm ist sozusagen nebensächlich. Hatte man in Hamburg plötzlich ein Saal mit 2000, 3000 Sitzplätzen, irgendwie also riesig, riesiger Rang, da könnte man sozusagen so einen kommunistischen Parteitag machen. Und dann kam eine Idee auf, dass man nämlich auf der Bühne steht und sagt, damit das hier alles ein bisschen schneller geht, defragmentiert doch mal den Saal. Also Leute, die neben sich einen leeren Sitzplatz haben, rücken einfach auf, damit die Leute, die vom Rand kommen, sich sofort reinsetzen können und nicht erst auf den durchgehen und so weiter und so fort. So.
Ich sitze aber gerne am Rand.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein echtes Problem. So, 2012 fanden alle das eine mega Idee, schon allein, weil der Lindworm das als defragmentieren gelabelt hat. Toll. Und alle so wussten, ah, defragmentieren, technischer Begriff, ich bin ja ein Techie, also mach ich das jetzt. Ich weiß sofort, was gemeint ist, ich fülle die Lücke auf. So. Aber es war auch, glaube ich, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es vorher war in Berlin, also es ist alles so kuschelig und klein, die Männer unter sich und so weiter. Es war der Beginn einer deklarativen Moral. Jemand stand auf der Bühne und hat gesagt, wir defragmentieren jetzt. Beklären das nicht unter uns, es ist mir egal, wer da zwei Sitze weitersitzt, du rutschst jetzt einfach eins auf. So. In dieser Zeit, in der dann auch die Bühne immer größer wurden, in Leipzig war ja nochmal mehr Sitzplätze, glaube ich, und alles riesig, hat plötzlich diese deklarative Moral überhand genommen. Also man kommt ins Kongresszentrum ein in Hamburg und da hängt sofort eine Fahne, all creatures are welcome. Und zwar nicht als so ist es hier, sondern das ist ein Befehl. Verhalte ich hier bitte ordentlich. Ich frage nach Konsent und wir wissen, wir haben da keinen öffentlichen Sex, sondern bei allem wird bitte Konsent abgefragt. Also es ist einfach so ein deklaratives Momentum drin, bei dem man sich fragt, naja, aber ich seh dich doch mir gegenüber, können wir es nicht einfach unter uns klären? Müssen wir jetzt alles dem großen Herrgott und so weiter ausliefern? Und dieses Jahr hat es für mich so ein bisschen umgeschlagen. Also es war mir zu viel und es gab eine Situation, die da ganz interessant war. Ich saß mit Robert in Saal 1 und wir saßen am Rand. Und dann kam von vorne der Befehl zu defragmentieren. Da die Pausen zwischen den Talks ein bisschen länger waren, 25 Minuten, war es 25 Minuten lang aufstehen, reinrücken, macht Platz für die Leute, die jetzt reinkommen. Es war sozusagen Faktor C nerviger, als mir am Bahnhof zu erklären, dass ich bitte hier vor Taschendieben und so weiter meine Sachen. Es war wirklich nervig. Und dann hat der Typ hinter uns einfach gerufen, und was ist mit denen, die Angststörungen haben? Die möchten am Rand sitzen. Und ein Typ auf der Bühne wusste nicht mehr weiter. Er war sozusagen Schachmatt. Er war in seiner Wugnis einfach Schachmatt gesetzt. Weil, ach klar, Angststörung. Und in dem Moment hab ich auch gedacht, wir sitzen alle gern am Rand und wir brauchen dafür auch keine Entschuldigung. Also ich muss jetzt nicht vorlügen, ich hätte hier mega Angst vor den Leuten, die hier sind, vor der friedlichsten Crowd der Welt, muss ich plötzlich lügen, ich hätte Angst um am Rand sitzen zu dürfen. Nein, ich komme zuerst in den Saal, Umgangsform heute, ich setze mich an den Rand. Wer später kommt, trägt leider das Los in der Mitte zu sitzen. So und es widersprach komplett dieser deklarativen Moral, die mir von der Bühne vier Tage lang reingehämmert wurde. Also ich weiß auch nicht, man kann aus Verlegenheit von mir aus 20 Minuten lang auf der Bühne Witze erzählen und so weiter. Es gibt keine, also Leute wie Pupo oder so, die machen das wunderbar. Die stehen dann da und wissen so ein bisschen wie der Wind weht und erzählen dann Geschichten von der letzten Nacht und wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die aus völliger Verlegenheit, die selber nicht wissen, warum stehe ich hier auf einer Bühne? Warum habe ich mich bereit erklärt hier zu engeln? Warum bin ich in der Herhalt? Und dann müssen die irgendwie, ich habe ein Mikrofon in der Hand, ja ich mach mal defragmentieren. So und dann gehen die auf den Sack, weil sie glauben deklarative Moral, darauf haben wir uns geeinigt, das ist das Ding. Und ich würd sagen 2025 ist nicht mehr. Ich will keine deklarative Moral mehr. Wir haben das als Vorwurf schon häufiger thematisiert, weil nämlich den Voken immer unterstellt wird, die hätten eine deklarative Moral und ich würde jetzt sagen, das stimmt. Nur die ganzen Neurechten, die haben eben auch eine deklarative Moral.
Nur eine andere, ja.
Ja, ich will nicht, dass mir irgendwer erzählt, wie ich mit irgendwem umzugehen habe. Oh, da kommt ein Ausländer, der wird jetzt gehasst. Nee, das deklarative Moral. Die hat für uns so ein umgedrehtes Vorzeichen, aber ich sag das trotzdem, das fällt ohne Moral. Ich will keine deklarative Moral mehr. Ich will jetzt für 2025, das ist mein Aufruf, bitte interaktives Bulldozern. Ich weiß, ich als Mann groß gewachsen und so weiter, ich Bulldozer sowieso. Aber nachdem ich jetzt so ein bisschen sensibilisiert wurde, ich wünsche mir das auch von anderen. Wenn im Hotel ein Frühstücksbuffet ist, und man sieht eine Einflugschneise, um vorzudrängeln, um sich ein Ei zu holen, stellt man sich bitte nicht in diese Schlange und wartet bis Oma Erna fertig ist mit dem Rührei, das ein Meter weiter vorne steht. Die Leute, die dann am Buffet überholen und mal kurz über die Schulter drübergreifen, um sich was zu nehmen, machen es richtig. Die sind nicht zu verurteilen, weil sie gegen irgendeine sittlichen Gebote und so weiter und so fort, sondern sie haben gesehen, ich schaffe das ohne zu berühren, wir klären das hier unter uns. Wenn jemand was dagegen hat, einfach ansprechen und sagen, dieses Verhalten finde ich gerade blöd, okay, dann muss man sich halt anstellen. Aber solange das keiner anspricht, muss man nicht vorauseilend und was mich besonders nervt, eine Situation, also eine Standardsituation.
Nachts im Dunkeln als Fußgänger vor der roten Ampel und stehen bleiben.
Genau. Also in New York ist jetzt erlaubt, es gibt keine Fußgängerampel mehr. Es gibt Verkehrsleitsysteme für Autos. Wenn rot ist irgendwas, man darf als Fußgänger rübergehen, immer.
Wenn man kann.
Wenn man kann. Man muss es halt für sich klären und mit den Autofahren so ein bisschen und so weiter. So, diese Situation, wenn ich auf ein Fahrrad komme und eine Oma steht auf dem drei Meter breiten Weg, hat einen Hund dabei und zieht den Hund dann so ganz ängstlich zu sich, guckt mich an und deutet mir noch so, ich habe ihn hier wegfrei gemacht, dann ist das für mich fast wie eine Anklage, weil sie, ich, also ich, mein Selbstbild vermittelt aus ihrer Perspektive ist dann, ich sehe so gefährlich aus und so unfähig mein Fahrrad zu steuern, dass ich sie tot fahren würde, aber sie hat sich jetzt aus dem Weg geworfen sozusagen für mich. Nur ich wollte ja nur da lang fahren.
Können wir das jetzt mal ein bisschen auseinanderhalten, weil jetzt kommt ja hier alles zusammen, jetzt kann ich das kaum noch entwirren. Also das eine ist ja eine deklarative Moral. Da weiß ich, was du meinst. Ich wundere mich zweil, wenn ich zum Beispiel im Rahmen einer Gewerkschaft einen Vortrag halte, dass zum Beispiel bei der Ankündigung oder irgendwo auch noch mal hingeschrieben wird, dass man gegen Homophobie zum Beispiel ist, wo ich denke, ja, was denn sonst? Muss man es noch mal hinschreiben? Will man es noch mal extra sagen den Leuten? Was passiert, wenn man ihnen das nicht sagt? Würde mich auch mal interessieren bei Verdi oder so. Also ein bisschen eigenartig, ja nur so als ein Beispiel mal. Und da kann ich das sehr nachvollziehen. Jetzt ist es ja so, was du da schilderst mit diesen Reihen, Massen sind mit Unterträge. Ich weiß das auch, wenn man zum Beispiel eine Veranstaltung macht mit Pause, dann ist das sehr, sehr schwierig, Leute nach 20 Minuten wieder in einen Saal zu buxieren. Ohne Gewalt. Und deshalb kann ich natürlich auch verstehen, dass man da gewisse deklarative Momente und Appelle hat, damit das funktioniert. Das andere, was du ja da gerade ansprichst, und das ist ja dem auch geschuld, dass man es geschmeidig halten will eigentlich, ist ja, dass du dich gerne so ein bisschen schneller durchbewegen würdest. Und das ist natürlich so, dass wenn man in einer größeren Stadt lebt, man sieht, dass es also verschiedene Tempi gibt, in denen sich Menschen durch die Welt bewegen. Und das hat auch nicht immer was mit, weil jetzt werden manche sagen, ja die Vulnerablen und so, auf die achtet natürlich Stefan wieder nicht. Dann würde ich sagen, ne, ne, ne. Also wenn man zum Beispiel weiß, was ich jetzt hab, mehrmals in Frankfurt unterwegs über die Zeit geht oder so, da bummeln eben Leute, das ist ja auch ihr Recht, dass sie da bummeln dürfen. Nur ist das vielleicht nicht meine Sache. Und ich würde auch sagen, ich finde es ganz gut, wenn man Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung mitunter hat, aber ich fände es auch schön, wenn man mal die Zahl, die auf dem Schild steht, auch erreicht. Ja. Dass man also nicht, wenn 50 steht, versucht es mit 20 zu machen. Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, wo ich auch mir etwas mehr Flexibilität und Dynamik wünsche. Und da beim Hotel ist es tatsächlich inzwischen so, dass ich wieder dazu übergehe, das Frühstück abzuplasen, weil ich das nicht mehr aushalte.
Ja, also genau, das ist nämlich der Ausweg, dass man einfach in die Vermeidung geht. Beim Frühstück wäre das noch zu verschmerzen, aber es gibt sehr viele Sachen, das Wort ergreifen, das Wort behalten, wie auch immer, dieses höfliche Zurückschrecken, klein beigeben und so weiter und so fort. Also es ist keine Sache des Regelwerks. Ich mag es weder, wenn Leute erstmal auf die Regeln verweisen, nachdem sie ein Wort bekommen haben oder so Sprüche machen wie ach, sehr schön, dass eine Frau hier auch mal was sagen darf oder wie auch immer. Also dieses schnippische Deklarieren von Moral finde ich genauso nervig, wie auf der Bühne diese ewig langen Präampeln, die irgendwie abgefeuert werden, Plakate, die da irgendwie hängen, die wirklich humorbefreit bis zuletzt. Die Hauptsache, alle fühlen sich auf der sicheren Seite. Ich möchte jetzt, dass wieder Spielräume erarbeitet werden.
Ja und auch Selbstverständlichkeiten nicht nochmal benannt werden.
Genau.
Also ich muss im Jahr 2024 bei einer Gewerkschaftsveranstaltung oder auch bei irgendeiner Uni Veranstaltungen nicht darauf hinweisen, dass man gegen Homophobie ist. Das ist selbstverständlich. Wenn jemand sich da deviant verhält, gehört der geahndet. Ja. Dann muss man das sanktionieren. Aber ich muss nicht jede Selbstverständlichkeit, muss ich noch mal schreiben. Ich schreib dir jetzt auch nicht morgens ein SMS. Wenn ich aus dem Auto heute bei dir aussteige, erwarte ich, dass du mich begrüßt. Davon gehe ich aus, dass du das tun wirst.
Und dieses, dann muss das angesprochen werden. Das ist eben diese zweite Seite dieser Medaille. Wenn man von sich selbst das Gefühl hat, ach, ich bin ja irgendwie ängstlich, ich find's ganz gut, dass es so Regeln gibt und wenn die dann mal gebrochen werden, dann hoffe ich einfach, dass die Leute einfach wissen, was die Regeln sind, ohne dass ich es jetzt nochmal ansprechen muss. Nee, dann muss man es ansprechen. Also dieses berühmte, wie verhalte ich mich jetzt zu Weihnachten am Familientisch, wenn Onkel Egon irgendwas sagt. Das sind genau die Momente, wo man dann reingehen muss. Also wo man in Interaktionen und im persönlichen Gespräch, wo man sich nicht verlassen kann, auf dritte Größen das klären muss. Ich finde es ganz erstaunlich und die Bandbreite der Effekte und Wirkungen und warum das ein politisches Thema ist, sind riesig. Das werden wir dieses Jahr auch sehen. Aber ich finde es ganz erstaunlich, dass wir einen medialen Diskurs darüber haben, dass in Österreich jetzt die FPÖ regiert und irgendwie mit Trump und dann Musk im Schlepptau, dass jetzt in Europa in jedem Land plötzlich diese Profierung der Neurechten gibt. Und wie jetzt ja auch, sagen wir mal so ein 25-Jähriger, der ist mit 15 irgendwie bewusst geworden, dass man ja und so weiter am medialen Geschehen teilnehmen kann. Der kennt also nur Trump und Musk. Also wir wissen gar nicht, was das bedeutet und so. Und wir haben so einen medialen Diskurs, der einfach ausblendet, dass diese Leute nicht einfach mit, ich hab die größten Raketen und die Elektroautobranche ist irgendwie meine oder so was, sondern die haben relevante große Teile der Bevölkerung hinter sich.
Ja.
Also die AHD sendet immer als ob nicht ein Drittel ihrer Zuschauer AfD-Sympathisanten wären, sondern für alle so ganz selbstverständlich, oh jetzt kommt das Monster des Rechtsradikalismus und so. Dabei sind es die eigenen Zuschauer, es ist die eigene Belegschaft, es ist die eigene Nachbarschaft, es ist die eigene Familie. Und es wird völlig ausgeblendet, wenn man sich auf so ein Regelwerk verlässt und ach ja war schon immer so. Artikel 1 ist natürlich, ja also ich hab noch hier diese Schlesinger vom RBB, bevor sie da gefeuert wurde, die dann noch beim Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland, bei diesem Reporterforum treffen da und so. Auf der Bühne sitzt, ja ja also bei Artikel 1 bin ich total parteiisch. Und dann sieht man das aber in dem Programm gar nicht. Also da kommt dann einfach März zum Gespräch und darf dann kurz sagen, ja natürlich wollen wir gar keine Ausländer hier haben und so. Und da wird dann einfach drauf vertraut, dass dann der Zuschauer weiß jetzt schon, dass das nicht okay ist oder, das kann ich hier nicht klären. Ich kann jetzt einfach sozusagen die Talking Points abdingeln und so.
Ich glaube, was wir jetzt eigentlich erleben ist, dass wir eine große Normalisierung haben, die ja auch da zu sehen ist, wenn zum Beispiel Linnemann oder März sagen, dass die, die eine Doppelstaatsbürgerschaft haben, die Deutsche abgeben müssen, wenn sie zweimal straffällig werden. Das heißt also, Staatsbürgerschaft ist dann doch wieder an was geknüpft, an das Blut. Und nicht mehr hält man sich dann offenbar ans Grundgesetz. Also man sagt dann auch, dass man natürlich großen Abstand zur AfD hält. Aber ich würde gerne mal wissen, wenn man jetzt so Namen nennt wie Jens Spahn oder jetzt bei Springer Matthias Döpfner oder Ulf Poschert, wer kann mir denn mal die fundamentalen Unterschiede zu Alice Weidel aufzeigen? Es gibt ja noch zwei Punkte, die sind ja tatsächlich strittig. Das ist einmal die transatlantische Verbindung. Jetzt hat Alice Weidel auch mal so was gesagt. Ja, wir sind ja quasi die Sklaven der USA. Das wirft sie mal so dahin. In Wahrheit aber sehen wir ja, wie die AfD immer transatlantischer wird. Das Vorbild ist da Georgia Meloni. Sogar Maximilian Krah scheint sich von China ja loszulösen und richtet sich auch immer mehr auf Elon Musk und Donald Trump aus. Wir haben zugleich eine Entwicklung, bei der wir sehen einen Präsidenten in den USA, der sagt, Grönland wäre gut zu haben, außerdem auch noch Kanada und gleichzeitig sagt der Grüne-Kanzler-Kandidat in Deutschland, wir brauchen mehr transatlantische Partnerschaft und das 3,5 Prozent-Ziel. Ja was denn, um Grönland zu erobern, um Kanada zu okkupieren, was machen wir damit? Also das würde man gerne mal wissen. Und was man jetzt eben sehen kann ist, also diese transatlantische Sache ist auf jeden Fall bei der AfD jetzt ein Ding und die bewegen sich in die Richtung. Und der zweite Punkt, der noch kritisch ist und der ist ja auch schon krach auf die Füße gefallen und deswegen wollte ja Weidel auch schon mal Höcke ausrangieren, auch wenn sie den jetzt wieder näher an sich annimmt, ist natürlich die deutsche Vergangenheit, Stichwort Holocaust. Wie geht man damit um? Wenn da jetzt noch ein Umgang gefunden wird, der natürlich sensibler sein muss als das, was Kickl jetzt da macht, weil der muss sich nicht distanzieren, die sehen sich als Opfer die österreichischen Rechtsextremen, die konnten ja gar nichts dafür damals in den 30ern. Aber hier in Deutschland muss das ein bisschen differenzierter aussehen und naja eine Antwort wird ja bereits gegeben. Es gibt ja geradezu mit der AfD einen Netanyahu-Fanclub und damit stellt man unter Beweis, dass man aus der Geschichte gelernt hat. Das ist ja auch quasi dann die Doktrin von Springer und das muss reichen. Und sonst will man über Antisemitismus und so in Deutschland nur dann reden, wenn er von Muslimen kommt. So und das ist quasi das Angebot, das gemacht wird. Und da wird es noch einige Reibereien und so weiter geben. Aber dann steht eigentlich auch einer schwarz-blauen Koalition in Zukunft, nicht bei jetzt der Wahl, die uns ansteht, aber in Zukunft steht dem dann nichts mehr im Wege. Und man wird sehen, dass auch dann gerade die Springer-Presse, aber auch andere private Medien werden da fröhlich mitmachen und sagen, ja so ist es jetzt leider oder wirtschaftspolitisch ist es aber auch vernünftig, was man dann meint. Also mehr Sozialkürzungen, mehr Lohndruck und so weiter.
Ja, all das sind Probleme, die müssen jetzt, also da muss man diskursfähig sein. Wenn man Journalist ist und man sieht solche Probleme, muss man auch mal gerne erklären können, wo liegt das Problem. Man muss dann eine funktionale Analyse, einen Verweis auf das Grundgesetz, einen Verweis auf Geschichte, auf irgendwas ist alles nichts wert. Also das hilft niemandem weiter. Keine Deklaration, keine Moral, sondern Achtung. Also dieses interaktive Prinzip, ich hab bei Lumans Moral der Gesellschaft da entsprechend empfohlen. Das sind diese Bücher der Stunde und so finde ich eben auch Eva Illouz.
Ja, wir sprechen über dieses Buch, Exklusive Moderne von Eva Illouz. Ich sage es gleich, das Buch ist Mist, aber Stefan findet es großartig.
Ich finde es genial. Man kann nicht besser in dieses Jahr starten als mit diesem Buch.
Ich möchte empfehlen, dass so eine Soziologie braucht wirklich gar keinen Menschen. Das ist auch keine Soziologie. Das ist schlechte Literaturwissenschaft. Wir werden darüber diskutieren. Ich glaube aber, es ist symptomatisch für unsere Zeit, dass so ein Buch jetzt da erscheint und ja auch viel Lob bekommen hat. Also du bist ja jetzt nicht der einzige, der das lobt, um das schon mal deutlich zu sagen. Ich bin da eher glaube ich in der Minderheitenposition. Also muss hart kämpfen, aber das werden wir im Salon tun. Außerdem habe ich was Schönes. Guck mal hier wie opulent. Das ist die große neue Lagerfeld Biografie, die den Titel trägt Paradise Now. Über die wird zu reden sein. Dann habe ich einen Roman von einer türkischen Autorin, beziehungsweise es ist eine deutsche und sie hat ihn auf deutsch geschrieben, kommt ursprünglich aus der Türkei, Theser Öslü. Dieser Roman ist aber 40 Jahre alt, ist nie auf deutscher Schiene, ist aber auf deutsch geschrieben und erscheint jetzt zum ersten Mal hochinteressant. Dann gibt es einen langen Essay zum Thema Netflix, zum Casual Viewing, nämlich Netflix produziert Filme für Leute, die gar nicht gucken, sondern die Filme hören.
Wie hören?
Na ja, man kann die Filme gucken, aber man muss, um die Reals zu verstehen, muss man sie nicht gucken. Es ist wirklich hochinteressant, wie sich das alles dort verschoben hat.
Naja, das ist ja heute schon All- und Tagesthemen. Das sind ja Nachrichtensendungen, die die Bilder nicht brauchen.
Richtig, aber bei Filmen hatte man sich ja mal darauf geeinigt, ob das Bild eigentlich das Wichtigste ist und wie das mit einem visuellen Medium zu tun ist.
Vielleicht, wenn alle drei Jahre ein Nolan-Film kommt.
Nein, nein. Und ich habe dieses sehr lange Interview gelesen, das Adam Tuß einem chinesischen Magazin gegeben hat, in dem er sich verortet als engagierter Intellektueller, sich gegen gewisse marxistische Theoretiker stellt, aber auch ein bisschen was gegen MMT sagt. Es ist ein hoch, hoch interessantes Interview. Man lernt sehr viel und vielleicht kann man sich da auch selbst noch mal sehr gut dann verorten. Und es gibt auch noch Musik, diesmal Brahms.
Okay, wir lesen, nachdem ich ja früher schon darauf hinwies auf das Buch von Livia Gerster über die Neuen im Bundestag. Michael Schlieben hat in der Zeit so eine Bilanz gezogen, die Leitenden der Generation Kühnert, das ist eigentlich aus diesen 49 geworden. Außerdem, wie werden wir mit 2025 fertig? Aus reinem Amüsement, es gab eine lange Liste in der Zeit. Mehrere Autoren haben Vorschläge gemacht, wird es ja, mehr oder weniger absurde. Außerdem der Think Tank von Ian Bremmer, der bekannt dafür ist, immer mal so ein bisschen populäre geopolitische Aussagen oder so zu machen, hat jetzt die großen globalen Risiken aufgeschlüsselt. Zehn Stück, die gehen wir mal durch. Also sozusagen Überblicksarbeit. Und Hoss und Hopf haben ein Buch.
Man muss das sagen für die Leute, die das nicht kennen. Also Hoss und Hopf ist so ein rechtsradikaler Podcast.
Also er ist nicht rechtsradikal.
Aber er ist so ein Podcast, der sagt, Deutschland ist nicht mehr Deutschland. Er hat Bitcoin, geht nach Dubai und beobachtet von dort aus Deutschland, wie es den Bach heruntergeht.
Genau. Was wir ja kennen aus vielerlei Richtungen.
Damit kann man gut Geld machen.
Damit kann man gut Publikum aufbauen. Und dieses Buch ist, also ich kann kurz schildern, ich hatte es nicht in der Hand und uns interessieren auch nicht die Inhalte. Dieses Buch hat 365 Kapitel, nämlich für jeden Tag soll man eine kurze Motivationsspritze und so weiter.
Also man liest jeden Tag noch so eine halbe Seite. Toll.
Ja, in deren Podcast selber thematisieren sie, dass der eine zu dem anderen sagt, ja und um mich überraschen zu lassen, habe ich ja auch deine Sachen gar nicht gelesen, bevor wir es in Druck gegeben haben. Das ist ja besonders interessanter herangehensweise. Und wir lesen nichts aus dem Buch, sondern wir lesen die Spitzenrezensionen aus Deutschland. Dieses Buch hat auf Amazon über 800 Rezensionen. Wir fragen uns natürlich alle, 200.000 Verkäufe. Wer hat das denn so gekauft? Also wir lesen die Rezension der verifizierten Käufer.
Das hat sich 200.000 mal verkauft?
Sagen die selber. Na die stehen ja auf den...
Na gut, man klatscht ja beim Media-Control.
Genau, also es hört schon irgendwie so hinhauen. Nur die Frage ist halt, wie kommt man zu 200.000 Verkäufen? Und was sagen die Käufer? Also wir werden uns ein paar Gedanken über den Buchmarkt machen, denn wir sind ja selber Teilnehmer des Buchmarktes. Dazu ein kleiner Hinweis, auf deine Empfehlung hin gibt es auch für die Kinderwüste eine Signieraktion. Also die Frage, Stefan wo soll ich denn ein Buch kaufen, wo hilfst dir am meisten? Ist endlich entschieden. Es gibt eine Seite autorenwelt.de, bei der die Autoren sogar beteiligt werden im Umsatz. Das wusste ich gar nicht. Also wir kriegen von der Marge dieses Buchhändlers auch nochmal Geld. Und ich kann ja kurz sagen, für das Autor sein an sich, kriegt man 10%, da der Verlag mir gegenüber sehr gönnerhaft war, was ich gut finde, 11%. Dieser Buchhändler legt nochmal 7% drauf. Also sozusagen wie bei Amazon dieses Affiliate-Programm oder so. Dadurch, dass die halt keine Schaufenster, Lager, Toiletten für die Öffentlichkeit, wie auch immer.
Aber ganz wichtig ist ja, was Autorenwelt anbietet, nämlich du signierst es und du signierst es nicht nur, sondern du widmest es auch.
Man kann mir auch Widmungswünsche, also es bleibt dann nicht nur bei der Unterschrift, sondern ich nehme dann die ganze Palette und schlage mir einmal vor den Kopf und sage, oh Gott, in jedes Buch jetzt individuell, aber keine Ahnung, wird schon klappen.
Also damit er auch mal ans Arbeiten kommt, bestell das Buch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie du das machen wirst. Also ich habe knapp 1000 Bücher damals signieren müssen mit Ann-Christine zusammen und das hat viele Stunden gebraucht, aber wir haben nicht noch Widmungen reingeschrieben, weil ich dachte, meine Handschrift ist so hässlich und ich bin froh, wenn ich meinen Namen drin habe.
Die Widmungen sind Vorschläge. Also ich schreibe jetzt keine Geburtstagsgriese oder länger ab, sondern kurz. Ja, kurz.
Okay, wir sind gespannt. Ja, und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr die 29er teilt, weiter verbreitet, in WhatsApp-Gruppen verschickt, wenn ihr gute Kommentare da lasst auf den Plattformen, auf denen ihr das hört. Und wir wären regelrecht begeistert, wenn ihr auch den Salon abonniert. Das ist ja die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Und es ist nicht nur eine Unterstützung, sondern man bekommt auch was dafür, nämlich wir haben hier einige hunderte, ich über tausend Seiten gelesen und wir werden jetzt gleich ausführlich über Eva Illus und über diese Soziologie streiten.
Wer mal wollte, dass Wolfgang und ich auch mal nicht einer Meinung sind.
Heute geschieht's. Das kann ich also ganz fest versprechen. Jedenfalls ist das ganz einfach den Salon zu abonnieren. Man kann das über Apple tun, wenn man den Podcast eh über Apple hört. Dort braucht man dann nur das Anklicken und sofort ist man drin für, ich glaube, 3,90 Euro.
3 Euro im Monat?
Ja, bei Apple ist es etwas teurer wegen der Gebühr.
Bei Apple gibt es aber einen Probe-Monat.
Ah, okay.
Man kann bei Apple sich warmhören und dann bei Steady für 3 Euro buchen.
Und bei Steady richtig kann man für 3 Euro buchen. Das heißt, man geht auf die Seite neu20er.de, da ist ein goldener Button, auf den klickt man, da kommt man sofort zu Steady. Es ist kinderleicht, man kann den Podcast dann einfach immer so weiterhören, wie man das jetzt auch tut. Man kann es also auf seinen Podcatcher sich anhören. Wer bei Patreon ist, kann auch dort den Podcast finden, findet auch dort alles aus den letzten Jahren. Ich glaube, die ersten anderthalb Jahre sind nicht dabei. Aber auch Patreon, wer da schon ist, kann dort ein Abo abschließen. Ab 3 Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Und da würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt. Und wir sollten vielleicht jetzt noch sagen, die Live-Termine. Es ist ja so, dass wir im Salon schon gesagt haben, dass wir wieder vier Live-Salons machen. Und jetzt hatten die quasi das Vorzugsrecht. Und nun sind aber noch ein paar Karten zu haben. Die erste Veranstaltung, die erste Salon ist ja schon ausverkauft. Im März, aber im Juni könnte noch was frei sein.
Also von allen Tickets sind ungefähr oder waren vor Weihnachten noch so ein Drittel. Also viel ist es nicht, aber die Termine sind.
Ja, März ist weg, dann aber den 6.
Genau, 20. Juni.
Ja, 20.6.
Dann Freitag, der 19. September und Freitag, der 19. Dezember. Und die Mail ist neuezwanzigeratdkas.de Kas mit AE. Aber das ist in den Show Notes verlinkt, wie man so schön sagt.
Wunderbar, dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich zu einem heißen Streit im Salon.
Ich werde, Wolfgang, auf die neuen Grundbegriffe weichklopfen. Es ist nicht nur Gefühle und Gemütszustand. Es kommt ein neuer hinzu.
Ich habe viele Gefühle beim Lesen dieses Buches gehabt, aber keine positiven.
Bis gleich.